لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم بينهم 150
مليونا في امريكا وضعنا تدابير لمنع ارسال
رسائل نصيه للمستخدمين دون 16 عاما ولا
نعارض اي مساله تتعلق بالخصوصيه تم بناء
جدران حمايه للبيانات الامريكيه وباشراف
موظفين امريكيين وهم فقط من يمكنهم الوصول
للبيانات الامريكيه التي ستكون تحت رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه الامريكيه اننا ناخذ
المخاوف الاميركيه على محمل الجد ولن نسمح
بالتلاعب ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه
مسؤوليتنا تتمثل في حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين وملتزمون بذلك نحن الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم بيانات شفافه لسنا شركه
حكوميه وستون في المئه من الاستثمارات
اجنبيه
وجلسه الاستماع مشاهدينا في الكونجرس
لرئيس التنفيذي لا زالت مستمره ننتقل
ونستمع اليها
المعلومات ليست بحاجه
كل هذه المناقشات ولهذا السبب فان تشريعا
بحمايه الخصوصيه قد يكونوا مساله ضروريه
سؤال واود الاجابه بنعم ام لا هذه
الحصص الخاصه بالتيك توك تقوم باستخدام
المعلومات من شركات ام ومن شركات تابعه او
شركات فرعيه
وتستخدم بيانات
المستخدمين لهذا التطبيق في الخارجي نعم
السابق من اجل اغراض التشغيل
وكان يتم العمل على تخزين كافه البيانات
هنا
والاشراف عليها من قبل الموظفين امريكيين
ما من شركه اخرى بما في ذلك اي شركه
الامريكيه سوف تتخلى عن واجبته هذه مساله
يجب طرحها على هذا القطاع فيما يتعلق
بمشاطره المعلومات اود ان اعلم من خلال من
خلالك واقتبسوا هنا انه كل شيء تراقبه
الصين هذا ما يقال الناس الذين كانوا على
الاتصال مع هذه المعلومات الحساسه كانوا
يقولون هذا الامر كيف ترد على هذا
الاقتباس لا اوافق على هذا الامر اعلم انك
قد لذوافق لكن سؤالي هو انه كيف يمكن
لموظفا في شركه ان يقول ان هذا غير صحيح
لا استطيع ان اتحدث عن هذا الشخص فانا لا
اعلم من هو وما الذي قاله او لم يقل هناك
ما اقوله انه بناء على على منصبي في هذه
الشركه فان هذا التصريح غير صحيح لسوء
الحظ
اعتقد انني تزوجت وقتي لكن لابد لنا ان
ننظر الى هذه الوقائع
نعطي الكلمه
للسيده
هل انت على درايه بان
هل انت على درايه بتعليقات رئيسي مجلس
الاداره
من الحزب الشيوعي الصيني الذي قال بانه
سوف يتم استخدام بلدان مختلفه وجماهير
مختلفه من خلال من خلال لقطه فيديو مختلفه
على ذراعي بهذه التعليقات وكما اشرت بان
رئيسه المجلس
روجرس كان قد تحدثت عن ان رئيسك تابع
للحزب الشيوعي صنيعي هل هذا صحيح كلا هل
لديك اتصالات معه كلا
نعم مع الرئيس التنفيذي
زميلتي كانت قد تحدثت عن ان او جنوب عن ان
انك على اتصال مع
المستشار الامريكي كذلك ايضا اكدت زميلتي
بان الشركه الام
لدايب
يمكنه ان تصل الى المعلومات المستخدمين
لابد لنا ان نكون اكثر تحديدا لا اتحدث عن
مشروع
بعض البيانات قد تكون
مكشوفه
للجميع لكن كنت قد اجبت على سؤال الجميع
زميلتي بان هذه المعلومات متاحه لكن
بايدنس قامت
باخفائي معلومات حول انشطه المؤسس لهذه
الشركه يمكنك ان تنظر الى موقع الشبكه ومن
خلال بعض الصفحات التي حصلنا عليها من
موقع
فهناك
تهمه لقيام الحزب الشيوعي الصناعي
للعمل على ارشفت بعض المعلومات المتعلقه
بالمستخدمين هل يمكن
ان تحظى بعضوا من الحزب الشيوعي في مجلس
ادارتها هل هذا صحيح كلا
مملوكه من قبل صينيين وانت تتحدث وانت
تتحدثين عن شركات فرعيه لابد لي ان امضي
في السؤال الاخر قلتم مرارا بانهما من
تهديدا لهذا التطبيق
وللامريكان اذا لم يكن هناك اي تهديد
الامريكيين او
لامن بيانات بامن بيانات لماذا اذا يمكن
يمكن للاداره العليا في
ان تقوم بالاستهزائي
السوسيه
ارتباطي هذا التطبيق
بالصين اذا لم يكن اي لديكم اذا لم يكن
لديكم اي شيء
هل يمكنك ان تقول لماذا تقومون بالاستخفاف
بهذا الامر اود ان اشير
اود ان اعير اهتمامك الى هذا الفيديو
القصير الذي سوف نعرضه على الشاشه ان سمحت
[موسيقى]
هذا الفيديو قد تم نشربه قبل عشره ايام
وما لفت انتباهي كلمه او عباره ان
وقد تم نشره قبل عقده الجلسه الاستماع هذه
في الولايات المتحده والامر المثير للقلق
بانه قد قد اطلق على رئيسه
الجلسه هذه باسمها
وانتم
اقريتم بانه لديكم
موقفا قويا ضمن تمكين العنف هل يمكن
استخدام هذه المنصه من اجل نشر العنف او
من اجل الدفع المنظمات المتطرفه بما يدفع
لحدوث
تهديدا لعمه الناس
فهذا الفيديو قد تم نشره منذ اكثر من 41
يوما يشكل تهديدا على رئيسه المجلس والناس
الحاضرين في هذه القاعه ولا يزال حتى
اللحظه موجودا على منصتكم وهل تدفعون
للاعتقاد باننا يمكنكم الحفاظ على سريه
وخصوصيه مليون مواطن امريكي وحمايه
الاشخاص الموجودين في هذه القاعه اعتقد
انها هذا تلاعب فاضح
لمدى
طردي الناس للمخاطر
ممن يستخدمون
تطبيق تيك توك ولا سيما بان هذا يعود بخطر
داهم على رئيسه الجلسه هذه
تعلمون بانه لا يمكنكم لا يمكنكم حمايه
بياناتي هذه اللجنه او المستخدمين 150
مليون لان هذا هو امتداد لما تقوم به
الحكومه الصينيه الشيوعيه او الحزب
الشيوعي في الصين هل لي ان ارد
خمس دقائق شكرا جزيلا انني سعيده
لعقد جلسه الاستماع هذه اليوم ودعيني اؤكد
بان الحكومه الصينيه تشكل تهديدا خطرا
ومباشرا
على
المراهقين في بلادنا ولا يمكننا ان نتعامل
عما تقوم به تيك توك وبعضه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه الاخرى الممثله
ولابد لي ان اطلب حاله الشفافيه من قبل
كافه المنصات بشان المصفوفات التي
يستخدمونها عند اشتراك المستخدم لهذا فان
شفافيه لا بد من تطبيق قانون الشفافيه
شفافيه
عدم استخدام المصفوفات يتم تطبيقها بناء
على العرق او الجنس او اي خصائص اخرى
للمستخدمين وايضا
يرمي هذا القانون لاستخدام مصروفات امنه
تخضع لرقابه اشرافيه
مسوده القانون هذه ايضا تطلب من تلك
المنصات ان تنشر التقاريرا
تتحدث فيه عن الممارسات المستخدمه والتي
اعتقد يجب ان تشكل منطلقا لتمكين قدره
الاشراف
حيث تكون ذات مغزى السيد نعم ام لا هل
تعتقدون ان متطلبات
الممارسات السنويه المعتاده التي يتم
تطبيقها على منصتكم سوف تكون مفيده نعم ام
لا نعم
مزوده شفافيه هذه تطلب من المنصات ان
تحتوي على سجلات تفصيليه تصف المصفوفات
واجراءاتها
وفقا للجنه الفيدراليه عملا بقانون
الخصوصيه
ومعايير التحديد هل تقوم تيك توك
بالاحتفاظ بسجلات تصف من خلالها
الاجراءات الخاصه بالمصروفات لابد لي ان
نتحقق
اللي اعطيك تفصيل تفاصيلا عن السجلات التي
تشيرين اليها على مر السنوات الماضيه خرجت
معلومات تبعث على دار بشان قيام بعضهم
شركات تعنى
بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التي تقوم بنشر التطرف السياسي والعنف ومع
ذلك تم التراجع والتغاضي عن مساله التحقيق
في هذه المساله من قبل تيك توك هل هذا
السلوك تجدونه مقلقا وهل تقوم تيك توك
باجراء دراسات خاصه حول المصفوفات
المتعلقه بتوزيع نماذج تتعلق بالسلامه
والصحه الخاصه بالمستخدمين
وهل تعتقدون انه ان لم تكون لذلك فانه يجب
فعل فعل هذا الامر اعتمادا على الاطراف
الاخرى والباحثين من جهه ثالثه قد تكون
هذه مساله فمثلا نعمل مستشفى بوستن التي
تنص على استخدام هذا التطبيق لمده 20
دقيقه
دون 18 عاما
ان محتوى تيك توك يعتمد على تشجيع
المستخدمين لقضاء فتره زمنيه اطول في
مشاهده هذا التطبيق مما يساعدك
مما يساعد على نشر فيديوهات قصيره
المده الزمنيه هل تقوم تكتك سيد شو لديها
سياسات مختلفه في تعظيم المحتوى المرتبط
بالاكتئاب او القلق
ام انها تتعلق بمسائل تخص الصحه والرياضه
اذا شرفتم اذا كان لكم ان تشرحوا هذه
السياسه
الاجابه هي نعم فنحن نعمل على
وضع سياسه بحيث يكونوا من خلالها المحتوى
غير مضر فمثلا
اللياقه البدنيه
المفرطه هي واحده من الاشياء التي نعمل
على بنائها من خلال التعاون مع الخبراء
وخلص للمستخدمين الصغار بالنسبه
للمستخدمين الذين ينخرطون في محتوى مضر
فانه من الضروره ان تقوم التيك توك باتخاذ
التصرفا لوقف ذلك بدلا من نشره اعتذر
لم اكن واضحا اولا اي شيء يقوم
باحداث ضرر فسوف نقوم بازالته من التطبيق
اما المحتوى الذي لا يكون بطبيعتهم مضرا
فمثلا بعض
اشرطه الفيديو التي تتعلق باللياقه لاشخاص
يركضون 100 ميل فمثلا قد لا يكون هذا مدرا
والخبراء يقولون بانه يجب عدم مشاهدته
بصوره مستمره من قبل الشباب
اننا نعمل على هذا الامر
السيد براك من فلوريدا خمس دقائق شكرا
السيده الرئيسه
المصفوفات تقدم محتوى مضر على وجه التحديد
للاطفال حتى انها تبعث على
العمليات
الانتحار وتسبب الاكتئاب
فهناك مخاوف بشان سلامه هذا التطبيق وهناك
مقطع نشر بعنوان فرنسي ستار
على منصتكم قد
يعرفه البعض بانه قد يبعث على الاختناق او
مما يشجع الاطفال على تبني هذه التصرفات
وتكون النتيجه وفاتهم وهنا لابد لي ان
اشطر قصه
وهو شاب في السادسه عشر من عمرها الذي فقد
حياته بطريقه ماساويه
اود ان اشكر والدي وهم معنا هنا اليوم
ان نظهر ما يلي السيد ان شركتكم قامت
بتدمير
حياتي هذه الاسره
لقد دمرتم حياتهم
وانني معجب بشجاعه
ووالدي
لمشاركه هذه القصه بهدف تجنب حدوثها مع
اسر اخرى
من خلال المحتوى الذي شهده لم يكن هناك
فرصه
للاكتشاف او الاستطلاع ولم يكن محتوى من
مبدع او من شخص خلاق
او من مضمون تعليمي او ثقافي يراه الناس
في الصين بل كان
بل كانت عباره عن
صفحات قد تكون وصفه للانتحار من غير
المقبول انه بعد كل هذه هي المخاطر التي
نراها فما زلتم تدعمون بان تيك توك تعد
ماركه
تزاول امورا خلاف ذلك
هل لكم ان تشاطروا هذه هذا المحتوى مثلا
مع اطفاء مع اطفالك هل ترغب منهم ان
يشاهدون مثل هذا المحتوى واود ان احذر
الجميع الذي يشاهد قد تجدون طبيعه المحتوى
مزعجه لكن لابد لنا من الاطلاع عليه
[موسيقى]
ان تكنولوجيا التي تستخدمونها تؤدي بصوره
حرفيه الى الوفاه والموت نعم ام لا هل
تتحملون المسؤوليه الكامله
عن المصروفات التي تقوم من خلالها تيك توك
بوضع اولويه بشان المستخدمين
اود ان ابدا بالقول انه من المؤسس جدا ان
نسمع هذا الامر نعم ام لا سوف اعيد السؤال
هل هل ستحملون المسؤوليه الكامله حول
المصروفات التي تستخدمها تيك توك في
محتواها الذي له اولويات نعم ام لا
نحن
نعير اهميه لهذه المسائل ونقدم المصادر
نعم ام لا ارى بانك لا ترغب بالاجابه عن
هذا السؤال
في بشان تتحمل بشان تحمل
شركتكم المسؤوليه عن الضرر الذي تتسبب
بهذا امر مؤسف ولهذا السبب فان الكونغرس
لابد له ان يتبنى
قانون ان يتعلق بالخصوصيه والامن من اجل
اعطاء الامريكيين قدره اكبر للسيطره على
المعلومات وحمايه اطفالنا لابد لنا من
انقاذ اطفالنا من شركات
تقنيه المعلومات مثل شركه مثل شركه التي
تقوم بالتلاعب بحياتهم من اجل مكاسبكم
الخاصه
سيده الرئيسه
السيده كاسر من شكرا السيد الرئيس زملائي
انها حاله تدفع على الاستعجال للكونجرس
لتبني مسوده القانون